.
AND THAT'S FOR JOINING US.
IT'S TIME FOR ANDERSON.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
AND WELCOME TO WHAT MIGHT BE
CALLED THE PERFECT PHONE CALL
STAGE INVOLVING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
PERFECT PHONE CALL WAS THE CALL
THAT GOT HIM IMPEACHED.
HE CALLED IT A PERFECT PHONE
CALL AFTER HIS SUPPORTERS AND
ENABLERS MADE A SLEW OF EXCUSES,
NONE OF WHICH HELD UP.
HE EMBRACED THE CALLED AND SAID
IT WAS PERFECT.
THAT IS WHERE WE LANDED OF
UNPRECEDENTED REVELATIONS SINCE
THE FBI AGENTS EXECUTED A LAWFUL
SEARCH WARRANT AT MAR-A-LAGO AND
CAME AWAY WITH 11 SETS OF
DOCUMENTS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE.
RUDY GIULIANI HAS MADE THE
PERFECT PHONE CALL EXCUSE.
>> NOW THEY WANT TO MAKE HIM
RESPONSIBLE FOR HAVING TAKEN
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND
PRESERVED THEM.
REALLY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, IT'S NOT REALLY
ABOUT TAKING THE DOCUMENTS, IT'S
ABOUT DESTROYING THEM OR HIDING
THEM OR GIVING THEM TO THE
ENEMY.
>> RIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT TAKING THEM
AND PUTTING THEM IN A PLACES
THAT ROUGHLY AS SAFE AS THEY
WERE IN IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> TAKING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTED,
SOME MARKED CLASSIFIED SCI IS AS
UNSAFE AS KEEPING THEM IN THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES AND WEST WING.
THE ESPIONAGE ACT ACTUALLY DOES
REFER SPECIFICALLY TO WILLFULLY
RETAINING DOCUMENTS AND FAILING
TO DELIVER THEM ON DEMAND TO THE
FEDERAL EMPLOYEE OR OFFICER
ENTITLED TO RECEIVE THEM.
AS WE SAID, THIS PERFECT PHONE
CALL EXCUSE HAS COME AFTER AN
EVOLUTION OF EXCUSES MADE BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S SUPPORTERS
FOR HAVING THE FILES STASHED AT
A COUNTRY CLUB.
HERE'S HIS YOUNGEST SONG THE
EVENING AFTER THE SEARCH.
>> MY FATHER HAS WORKED SO
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THEM FOR
MONTHS.
THE LAWYER THAT'S BEEN WORKING
ON THIS WAS TOTALLY SHOCKED.
I HAVE SUCH AN AMAZING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THESE PEOPLE
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN NO NOTICE,
THEY SEND 20 CARS AND 30 AGENTS?
>> SECOND YOUNGEST SON.
HE'S SUGGESTING IT CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE.
IT MAY HAVE COME FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR HIS LEGAL TEAM
ACTING IN BAD FAITH.
ONE OF HIS LAWYERS SIGNED A
LETTER IN JUNE SAYING NO CLASS
FEUD MATERIAL REMAINED AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
INVESTIGATORS FOUND THIS TO BE
UNTRUE AND OBTAINED A SEARCH
WARRANT.
AS FOR THE SEARCH HIMSELF, THE
FORM ARE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS PAINTED THE FBI AS
JACK-BOOTED THUGS.
SENATOR RICK SCOTT.
>> THIS SHOULD SCARE THE DAY
LIGHTS OUT OF AMERICAN CITIZENS.
IT'S LIKE WHAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT
THE GESTAPO OR PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
THEY JUST GO AFTER PEOPLE.
>> RICK SCOTT, FORMER GOVERNOR
OF FLORIDA COMPARING THE FBI TO
THE GESTAPO.
THAT WAS AUGUST 9th.
BY THE 10th, THE SUPPOSEDLY
RESPONSIBLE LAWMAKERS WERE
SUGGESTING WITH NOTHING TO BACK
IT UP THAT THE FBI HAD PLANTED
EVIDENCE.
>> DO I KNOW THE BOXES OF
MATERIAL THEY TOOK FROM
MAR-A-LAGO THAT THEY WON'T PUT
THINGS IN THOSE BOXES TO ENTRAP
HIM?
HOW DO WE KNOW THEY'LL BE HONEST
ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE BOXES --
>> WHAT'S IN THE BOX?
THE FORMER PRESIDENT GOT IN ON
THIS ONE AND BY WEEK'S END THE
MAN WAS DEAD AFTER TRYING TO
STORM THE FBI FIELD OFFICE IN
CINCINNATI.
BY THAT TIME, THOUGH, WE HAD
SEEN THE SEARCH WARRANT AND THE
ALLEGED CRIMES IT WAS PREDICATED
ON AND SAW THE INVENTORY OF WHAT
WAS TAKEN.
SO FOR A WHILE THE ARGUMENT WAS
THERE WAS NO CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS LEFT AT MAR-A-LAGO, IT
BECAME THAT THERE WAS 11 SETS OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ACTUALLY
WEREN'T REALLY CLASSIFIED AT
ALL.
>> THIS IS FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S OFFICE.
IT JUST CAME IN A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
AS WE CAN ALL RELATE TO
EVERYONE -- AS WE CAN ALL RELATE
TO, EVERYONE ENDS UP HAVING TO
BRING HOME THEIR WORK FROM TIME
TO TIME.
HE HAD A STANDING ORDER, THERE'S
THE WORD I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR,
THAT DOCUMENTS REMOVED FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE AND TAKEN FROM THE
RESIDENCE WERE DEEMED TO BE
DECLASSIFIED THE MOMENT HE
REMOVED THEM.
>> WHERE DO THEY FIND THESE
PEOPLE?
THAT ONE FAILED THE LAUGH TEST
AS WELL AS A SUBSEQUENT CNN FACT
CHECK IN WHICH 18 HIGH RANKING
OFFICIALS CONFIRMED THE NOTION
WAS RIDICULOUS.
>> THIS CASE WHAT ABOUT OBAMA?
>> DONALD TRUMP TWEETED THAT
PRESIDENT BARACK HUSSEIN OBAMA
KEPT 33 MILLION PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS, MUCH OF THEM
CLASSIFIED, HOW MANY PERTAINED
TO NUCLEAR?
WORD IS LOTS.
>> WORD IS LOTS.
TRUTH IS NONE.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY PUT OUT A REBUTTAL
OF ALL OF IT.
SO FINE, WHATEVER.
THERE WAS THEN OF COURSE ANOTHER
EXCUSE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS JUST
TOO BUSY TRYING TO STAY IN
OFFICE TO KEEP AN EYE ON THE
MOVES.
IF YOU ONLY START PACKING WITH
TWO DAYS LEFT TO GO, YOU'RE JUST
RUNNING LOW ON TIME, A FORMER
AIDE SAID.
AND IF HE'S THE ONE JUST
THROWING THINGS IN BOX